hey everyone it's awesome to be
here so my name is Nicholas I'm the
founder of
infinita that's a VC fund that's based
in prospera I live there and today I
want to talk about how we want to do a
bio acceleration Zone and specifically
the legal and infrastructure layer for
it but first I want to tell you a story
so what is balaji's favorite
three-letter agency FDA the
FDA
exactly so this is the story of how I
learned how the sausage is made true
story so I wanted to start a healthcare
analytics
company and I always do a lot of
customer research before so I talked to
this German
guy who was doing regulatory content
management and he was this family
business guy where there's these German
medium-sized companies that have like a
monopoly in a super specific
Niche that's what they did and I was
like what's that that looks like a you
know dock send for you know Regulatory
Compliance but I said not entirely a
little bit of that but we're actually a
logistics company so what do you mean a
logistics company we track
truckloads like literal truckload of
paper I was like what physical paper
like yeah we deliver that and we track
that and we offer that as a service it's
like what so if you're a brilliant
bioscientist
engineer and you know you can code up
you know a new drug small molecule
vacine on a computer and then you have
to do
this yeah I mean no wonder that's what
happens right so we have two major
problems s in biotech one is the value
of death which is like a funding in the
early stages and then E's law so irum
law is the reverse of Mo law so at the
same time as the rate of computing power
went up the rate of new drug development
went
down and it's not
inevitable until
1963 the FDA had to approve a drug in
three months otherwise you were allowed
to go on the market it's crazy right and
that's a problem because we now have
very promising science and technology
that could allow us to live for much
longer potentially reaching longevity
escape velocity as Auer deay has called
it I want that I don't know about you
guys so can we back to like pre-1962
times can we build like a more rational
legal and Regulatory
system and yeah we can so I live in
Prosper really good location this is an
aerial view that shows you how much
there is how much space there is to
build and prosper instituted this thing
here so a polycentric common law system
so the idea is um you need you should
have liability insurance otherwise you
have strong
penalties so the insurance effectively
becomes your regulator they don't want
you to mess up otherwise you they have
to pay but they also don't want you to
go out of business so they have the best
incentive to give you good
regulation that's safe while you can
stay Innovative I think it's a brilliant
idea and one company that's building off
of that legal template is this one
minicircle they did followon gene
therapy clinical trials under with an
IRB under the supervision of an American
clinic so it's FDA compliant it's just
massively reducing the cost of
bureaucracy and also just making it much
faster which is really the important
part for aage biotech not only only that
they can bring people there to take the
drug the one of their first patients was
this man Brian Johnson with a major
longevity influences this is socially
what potential there is if he comes for
that
already also another entrepreneur named
Greg nakagawa is building more
infrastructure around it and a pristine
dange of medicine hub for so we can have
hundreds of companies that can do
clinical trials there in medical tourism
so it needs a lot of technical stuff we
want to do like a voluntary certificat
FDA for example fractional usage
clinic and this is the space where we're
doing it I mean isn't this gorgeous
right I I would want to come here to get
like the most advanced longivity
treatments and my co-founder Lawrence
will talk a bit more about it we're now
doing another zalu there for two months
with bio scientists and entrepreneurs
that want to help us accelerate
longevity Long Live Italia let's live
forever and um you know up and up and
go